hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's once again time to delve into the
PlayStation Plus offerings coming up in
January 2018 every single one of these
titles will be available to download
from Wednesday the 3rd of January we
have a pretty good month ahead of us
with a triple-a action RPG a Dark Knight
crime fest a few point-and-click graphic
novels and a Rena shooter for the PS VR
and a pixel art horror outing that's
enough of that let's look at the game
starting with the beauties on ps4 first
up is an absolute masterpiece Deus Ex
mankind divided set in the cyberpunk
near future where man and machine are
fused together to create augmented
humans with superhero abilities Deus Ex
acts like a role-playing game as you the
player decides which mods to install and
upgrade if you want to dual wield blades
of death from your hands then cooperate
fancy taking it stealthy then grab the
cloaking tech to turn invisible for a
short period of time mankind divided has
something for every play style which
gives Deus Ex great replayability the
car combat hacking to dealth and social
interactions to name a few plus all the
mods and gun customization to keep even
a hardened warframe player happy the
game's narrative is quite compelling too
with the decisions and actions you have
taken during your playthrough impacting
the ending cinematic there's variations
to each of these but there's a good butt
and an alternative ending to unlock Deus
Ex is only one year old first releasing
in late 2016 and receiving a heap of
awards and Game of the Year nominations
and impressive review scores with IGN
awarding mankind divided nine point two
out of ten you have to give this one a
try it is worth it I promise you next up
is Batman the telltale series this is a
five-part graphic novel adventure as you
take the role of Batman and Bruce Wayne
just in case you're wondering you will
indeed receive the entire season all 5
episodes are yours to download
throughout January the gameplay
mechanics are split into three distinct
areas the first is point-and-click
movement
the second is multiple choice options
such as acting aggressively are a little
more passive the third element are those
QuickTime events requiring us to quickly
press buttons before unpleasant things
happen to the Caped Crusader but there's
also a fourth area which sets the game
apart from other telltale titles as
Batman is the greatest detective the
world has ever seen you will visit crime
scenes and manually piece together all
the clues it's exceptionally satisfying
it really is this version of Batman's
universe is unique from many of the
films and comics you've seen the way
Bruce meets and interacts with
characters like the Joker and Vicki Vale
will change your viewpoint on those
individuals and offers a different
perspective on many super villains - if
only for a fleeting moment like you'd
expect with an episodic adventure there
are multiple endings to each episode
although frustratingly
most of your actions have no consequence
in the slightest if you can get past
that then this is a great story
adventure showcasing Batman in a
different light than you're used to
fellow PlayStation virtual reality
owners our additional free game is star
blood arena this is a first-person arena
shooter in which you pilot one of nine
ships and shoot the [ __ ] out of
everything and anyone you can find the
single player is only really here as a
training mode for the real game which is
all about cooperative and multiplayer
mayhem so if you've never tried an arena
shooter in psvr then download this and
give it a try and if you don't have PS
BR yet download it anyway you never know
what the future holds
a quick note that's you is still
available but we've covered that so many
times in previous months so let's move
on to the ps3 over on the ps3 we have
the hack and slash Athan sacred 3 after
your ruler laussane allies himself with
demons and opens up an underworld you
and your hero pals decide to put things
right and slaughter tens of thousands of
enemies there's not really much more to
say about this what you see is what you
get but it seems to have very mixed
reviews with most trusted sites awarding
sacred between four and six out of ten
the book of unwritten tales also appears
on the ps3 and follows the story of
Fantasyland ad
tasia it's another point-and-click
adventure which we've received a huge
amount of recently on PS Plus take
control of a mage an elf princess a
furry alien or a good old narcissistic
human and learn about the world's
heritage anybody still playing these
types of games I would love to know on
the Vita we have yet another visual
novel this month in the shape of
Psychopaths mandatory happiness set in a
dystopian future Japan where people are
imprisoned for crimes they haven't even
thought about yet you will control two
characters I cannot pronounce their name
so I won't even bother one is searching
for their loved one and the other has a
bout of amnesia if you watch the anime
this could be a great addition as it
runs parallel to the broadcast show and
finally the last game for January 2018
is available on both beta and the ps4
uncanny valley
don't let the visuals push you away
uncanny valley is a survival horror
outing with an unsettling story at its
core playing as tom the security guard
on a night shift you explore a huge
facility with a flashlight to keep you
company already torn apart by his own
nightmares Tom now has to live them out
sounds absolutely lovely doesn't it so
there we have a 8 PS + titles for
January 2018 what are you grabbing this
month for me I'm going to try a pacifist
playthrough up Deus Ex and an aggressive
playthrough of Batman the telltale
series where I'm going to make Bruce
Wayne a complete dick let me know your
thoughts I'm Adam from Playstation
grenades it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
you